[Music]
hey you guys ever uh are in like a a
crowded area or something like that and
then you think it's just [ __ ] funny
to like airdrop some random people some
stuff i know i don't look at mo bro hell
yeah and what do you usually airdrop
people a photo of themselves
what oh that's actually creepy as [ __ ]
it's like drake
ryan is [ __ ] wild right it's wild no
the context is that i don't i don't like
when people are recording the concert in
front of you
like if you're standing behind someone
at a concert they're just going like
this yeah so then i just i take a
picture of them and i interrupt their
recording with an airdrop because it'll
wipe out whatever they were recording
yeah so i just cancelled everybody's
[ __ ] thing and they're all going dude
ryan's even more wild than i just
thought he was
so imagine though you're on a plane
you can't leave
you get air dropped this is part one of
two first you get airdrop this
wake up wake up wake up it's the first
of the month is that really the bone
though is that both thugs and sumerian
it's not bone sucks lyrics i'll give you
i'll give you a translation in just a
second
okay i thought that was really both days
later right that's part one of two
i hope they still make more matrix
so there's not shitty ones that's the
first part and it says
in um
ethiopian am amher americ by the way
okay that's the language it looks
ancient the the following text all right
is pretty much translated as
your family will bleed for your actions
you will suffer eternally for your
actions
this is why you know what what's stupid
chain letter they should not have the
everyone option on the airdrop as well
as followed by this
photo yo oh
[Music]
what do you do
scream
i look for the person that's going like
this and going
instantly i would tell everybody to
stand up who received it and my process
of elimination we're gonna find a
[ __ ] sense well that's pretty good
yeah okay
147 people on the plane received it how
many 147 people on the smart ones had
contacts only on their airdrop i'm
telling you guys isn't that crazy 147
people see that sometimes you can't even
[ __ ] send it to one guy are you
getting it what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah yeah yeah
this guy's airdrop hello works you know
what that means you know what that means
though right like if somebody has it
already set the contacts only it means
that they used that function before
because
like i only have used that function
before because nikki takes my phone and
just sends pictures to herself yeah but
i don't [ __ ] know even about that you
don't use airdrop [ __ ] no i i don't even
know how to use it but in the actual
[ __ ] airdrop is like it's like [ __ ]
wiping your ass it's like one of the
best things iphone ever did i only know
how to do crazy blockchain [ __ ] that
people most people [ __ ] have the back
of their brains blowing out but the
simplest iphone [ __ ] i'm like i don't
know how to do it these use the [ __ ]
text
and then [ __ ] it that and then whatsapp
or some [ __ ] barely i can't i just
deleted whatsapp because i was getting
so much spam oh all those chinese girls
always trying to talk some chicks
sending me pictures of their feet and
[ __ ] i'm like what the [ __ ] going on
that's better spam than some of the [ __ ]
i get
chinese girls are always trying to meet
up for coffee yeah or they're like
better spam than what he gets hey hey
are you friends with armando that was a
pretty interesting business discussion i
would love to continue and i'm like what
the [ __ ] these leads are getting so
creative huh have you ever get the uh
crypto chat rooms where they just start
talking about after spending more time
with this guy he [ __ ] helped me out
made me a million dollars really tell me
more about it oh my god the comments on
there we're doing so many jk videos too
oh those that's me i'll get mine that
i'll get ones that say like learn how to
make ten thousand dollars a day doing
this to bitcoin or whatever and i check
it out for a little bit
i like i go peep that game i just see
what it is no i love the ones that fun
like jakey vids and then it's like got
26 replies and everyone's like yeah dude
i use this and like oh my god like i
changed my life and then the next
person's like yeah i use this and like i
can't stop [ __ ] coming because
and how do they get it as soon as the
video's up like how did are they
subscribed or something
you know what though i will never get
that message on a plane because i have a
pixel
and i don't have errors now that you
said that everybody knows you have a
pixel aren't you counter culturalist you
get your google pixel green bubble one
of the biggest companies in the world
are you sure you're not you have their
phone yeah yeah i'm not a camera you
have a lot of gaming tendencies do i i
don't know
i suck at games though i die i think it
doesn't matter yeah because chick gamers
suck at games
so i think you're good
there's some great ones and i'm on the
record
so this flight
was delayed for two hours after
passengers were sent down we delayed the
flight over this did you figure out who
did it go find out who did that [ __ ]
doesn't it say sent from this person i
don't think it does after alerting the
crew to the messages the captain took
the decision to delay the flight and
informed border police of what had
happened border police was rushed to the
scene and quickly discovered that the
threats had been sent
by an 18 year old spaniard who later
admitted to being responsible
beat his ass yeah yeah
justice for air dropping a [ __ ] ton of
scares his pants down because he [ __ ]
needs to be spanked and just [ __ ]
whoop his ass and yeah
like dad's style dude i i go to the
airport yesterday coming to jk right i
dropped nikki off [ __ ] two o'clock
i'm like okay my flight's at five i'll
go chill a little bit
so i could go to one of the bars or
whatever and chill a little bit
and then i get there
we get on our spirit flight
we uh roll out to the tarmac
and then all of a sudden the pilot's
like it's been 45 minutes and he's like
yeah guys look we we have a brake issue
we're gonna have to let the brakes um
cool off for a sec
so then we sit there for another hour
then this lady gets up
and it's hot by the way it's it's
[ __ ] hot why don't they run the ac
it's a hundred [ __ ] whatever degrees
so yeah you're in the middle of tarmac
it's hot as [ __ ] they're trying to do ac
[ __ ] but nothing's working right so it
sucks this lady gets up and she's
[ __ ] pissed and by the way spirit
sucks communicating also spirit sucks at
everything they suck but this is real
this really happened you guys aren't
even about to [ __ ] believe what
happened okay so this lady gets up right
and she's like
charges towards the captain's door
and she's like [ __ ] knocking on the
door and she's like the captain's
supposed to tell us what the [ __ ] is
going on what the [ __ ] is going on right
and then she gets like they're like man
ma'am and all this [ __ ] and then she
gets pulled away and then um
she gets sat down and then we're sitting
there for another like 25 minutes
and then they're like
if anyone's a doctor on board please
like hit the call button because there's
a medical emergency and i'm like yo what
the [ __ ] is absolutely going on the
brakes are [ __ ] up ladies
and gentlemen
i know we're in the middle of the tarmac
though and they're making us all
put the slides up of the windows so it's
hotter we need to have visibility of
everything around us you know what i'm
saying dude so it's like okay cool it's
making the plane hot as [ __ ] and were
you in this outfit the whole time yeah
i'm not i'm even more dripped out more
than the all-gold one which you guys
will see soon
so then so then
uh
dude it was crazy so then this uh
they all of a sudden divert us back
they're like hey sorry everybody this
plane just doesn't want to take off
today we're going to go back to the gate
after two hours sitting in the middle of
tarmac in 100 degree weather did the
doctor come out we get we get brought
back to the gate but then before they
bring the doctor on board they have the
cops come in so we have to wait for that
the cops come in usher this lady out the
one that went to the front knocking on
the [ __ ] door and then they get the
medical emergency team in but it's like
why'd you get the lady out first she was
just a [ __ ] little tiny lady she
weighs probably 115 pounds
like like anybody could carry this lady
out one hand so then then uh yeah they
get the medical emergency personnel we
don't even know what the [ __ ] is going
on then we finally exit the plane i
don't i've been there since two o'clock
i finally flew out of uh vegas at 9 30
at night oh god it was crazy
brakes issue maintenance issue woman
charging the cockpit hot weather hot
weather and a medical emergency on the
same flight
and then um this lady apparently is
getting a 17 or 16 thousand dollar fine
what for knocking on the door
don't do that don't do that what the
[ __ ] knock on the pilot's uh cabin door
whatever the [ __ ] that is a fine up to
16 000 for every knock it's like a grand
it was crazy so and and the team was on
board the spirit team who were by the
way a bunch of [ __ ] i mean not
really their fault but the fact that
they threw the book at this lady like
that
they threw a book
like we're all hot and like okay
everyone's like losing their minds in
there right why are they just on board
everything i know dude it's crazy but
like the fact that they just like this
lady she just knocked the rattle in the
door she's just like her hands look so
small it's like a baby's hand
she can't express how she's hands
she's a small lady she's [ __ ] thank
you bart jesus
but it was but they really did like let
this lady have it with that like they
told the cops on her and all this [ __ ]
and it's like they don't have to do that
but look we have to do we just [ __ ]
have to yeah we can't do i'm like you
guys delight in this [ __ ] you guys are
sitting there like this and you [ __ ]
love that she was [ __ ] on you guys
and you get to throw the book at her
with your stupid little job you get to
do that [ __ ] which by the way i'm not
saying that [ __ ] them for that it's just
that they're they're stupid little piece
of authority they get to use over people
just like mall cops and all that kind of
[ __ ] when you give them that little
piece they like to use it against people
so they'll make up the profit like make
the conditions so shitty until someone
loses their mind then find that person
on them because there's probably other
people that that's how they keep the
costs down they're like don't worry some
somebody's gonna lose it any second
yeah everyone's gonna pay for your
luggage no more and immediately and
immediately too i saw i saw for a sec
this is a sim steve okay sim steve for a
second
and a lot of people are gonna be like
there's always symptoms okay i get it
but no um there was a dude who was
immediately like yeah okay lady so like
just because you're hot and you're like
you weigh 110 pounds like it's all about
you
like everyone here we want answers but
like you should get the answers first
it's like she's just trying to find out
what the [ __ ] going on dude like
literally there's no communication
nobody's [ __ ] saying he's all just
literally
wearing food yeah i'd like complain more
people asking the flight attendants and
everything too
yeah everyone was so they just wouldn't
answer nobody was giving us anything
they were just saying sorry the breaks
blah blah blah breaks and then like we
had to wait wait wait wait wait and then
we find out the plane's like not working
eventually and all this [ __ ] but like
nobody's saying anything like that we're
on there for two minutes or two hours
right so you're just sitting there
breathing all this hot hair around you
last time i um i flied back into vegas
this dude um almost died next to me uh
same thing spirit yeah spirit man um he
was just old dude he had a jumpsuit like
you too and then he was with his wife
like jogging your style right in the
morning you know he was kind of sleeping
and then he was just hey what's up
what's my name there i forgot his name
and then i'm like cool and then like
when we're about to land
she goes honey
wake up
wake up are you having a seizure and he
goes oh yeah
oh and then so like we're about to like
nonchalant this is because he's like
yeah like that he's like he's having a
seizure but he can't like and i'm like
oh shoot okay and then so i'm i hit the
help button right and then so like i
have my you know seat belt on and
everything but we're already landing so
that's when they make the announcement
the the [ __ ] seatbelt sign is on and
she goes excuse me it's right it's steep
outside we don't give cocktails right
now
and then so she's starting to panic and
she goes please get help please get help
and i'm just like no no it's an
emergency like he needs help right and
then so they get up and then they're
just oh he just doesn't want to drink or
something so they come over like is
anyone a doctor some people pop up
there's a nurse and i was just like well
let me get into another [ __ ] seat and
i got out of the way and i was like dude
this is [ __ ] nuts and everyone was
just trying to like make sure that he
stays awake
and then while we were trying to land so
the whole time the plane was landing it
hits the [ __ ] like the tarmac and
[ __ ]
and then like at the end of it i guess
like they got him to breathe they had an
oxygen machine or whatever and at the
end he goes
sorry everyone oh and everyone's like
everyone's like nah it's not your fault
man it's cool
that's cute i just remember spirit
airlines the latest five hours when we
were trying to go to hawaii for a
bargain as well that's a legion yeah
that's a legion was allegiant oh
probably a legion operated by spirit
you